michael audrey myers was born in the
year 1957 as the second child in his
family after his nine-year-old sister
judah in this video i'm only analyzing
the original timeline of michael's life
which includes the events of halloween
halloween two return revenge and curse
the date of michael's birth in this
timeline is not explicitly stated but in
halloween resurrection which is part of
a different timeline we learn this
michael myers
born october 19 1957.
both of these timelines start with the
same movie halloween which would imply
that michael was also born on october
19th in that movie i like to think about
the halloween timeline as a train map
which i call the halloween express so
think about it like this if we depart
from the station halloween one at
exactly 10 19 we can go straight and end
up in curse of michael myers or we can
go this way and end up at halloween
resurrection no matter which way we went
we still departed from the halloween one
station at 10 19. the counter-argument
to that idea is halloween 2018. in rick
rosenthal's halloween 2 we learned
michael myers and lori stroder's
siblings which would mean that they were
always siblings even in halloween one
however in halloween 2018 they don't
appear to be related because the 40-year
timeline does not pass through halloween
too however it's possible that they
still are related just nobody ever finds
out wasn't it her brother who like old
blooded murderlated all those teenagers
no
that's just a bit that some people made
up to make him feel better i think there
are other retcons that don't carry over
to other timelines so all i'll say with
certainty is that michael was born
sometime in the year 1957. yeah this is
gonna be one of those episodes of horror
history michael was three years old when
his sister lori was born in february
1961. his early childhood is presumably
a normal one until two and a half years
later when he is cursed by an ancient
demon known as thor to learn what really
happened to michael after disappearing
from haddenfield stick around to the end
of this video
[Music]
welcome to horror history and welcome
aboard the halloween express the
halloween timeline can be a little bit
confusing at times we've got many
different continuities branching out
from the first two movies then we've got
a reboot which isn't connected to
anything and halloween three a separate
world where the original halloween is
just a movie on top of that there are
comics and novels whose status in the
canon can be kind of unclear so to make
things easy for this episode we're going
to be traveling right down to the
original route as we analyze horror's
most iconic slasher michael myers was
named after a real life michael myers by
the original director john carpenter who
wanted to honor the european distributor
of his previous film assault on precinct
13. to understand how michael became the
soulless immortal killer that he is
we've got to take it way back to about
500 bce
[Music]
the myers family is descended from an
ancient druid tribe who worshipped great
astronomical deities the druids were a
mysterious celtic order known for their
studies of religious scriptures
philosophy astronomy and divine lore
they were said to make sacrifices which
sometimes included human sacrifices for
the sick or injured which allegedly
included the burning of huge wickerwork
figures filled with men not much is
known of the druid culture because they
did not keep any records but around 500
bce they did create an ancient alphabet
carved into stone and wood ruins these
runes were used for pagan rituals in
order to help the tribe predict future
events one of the icons was the symbol
of thorn which was designed after the
thorne constellation and was used to
represent an ancient demon that plagued
the celtic people
among the ancient druids
a demon that spread sickness destroyed
crops
brought death to hundreds of thousands
of people
according to celtic legend one child
from each tribe was chosen to be
inflicted with the curse of thorn while
knowledge of the demon thorn faded into
legend over the coming millennia the
bloodline of the tribe stayed intact and
one offshoot of the population ended up
in the midwest region of the united
states they continued to practice their
ritualistic sacrifices in fear of the
malicious demon and they called
themselves the cult of thorn in the
early 1960s the leader of the cult was a
man by the name of terence wynn who
worked at the sanitarium known as
smith's grove by day and used the
facility as a meeting place and worship
ground by night one child from each
tribe was chosen to be inflicted with
the curse of thorn to offer the blood
sacrifices of its next of kin on the
night of saman halloween the sacrifice
of one family meant sparing the lives of
an entire tribe so dr winn believed that
if he and his cults placed the curse of
thorn on one child the child would be
compelled to kill his entire family but
the rest of the tribe would be protected
from things like disease death plague
and drought for an entire generation i
do not know how their selection process
went but dr wynn ends up choosing a
six-year-old boy by the name of michael
audrey miles the curse must be placed
during the festival of samhain champaign
which is a gaelic festival of pagan
origins where the barrier would
supposedly be down between the real and
the unreal allowing sacrifices be those
crops animals or in the case of the
halloween movies human sacrifices to be
made samhain takes place every year at
the end of the harvest season today in
the northern hemisphere we call that
halloween night however in the eyes of
the cult some halloween nights were more
special than others the druids were also
great mathematicians and astronomers but
the thorn symbol is actually a
constellation of stars that appears from
time to time on halloween night whenever
it appears he appears i'd like to note
that the druids the pagans the festival
of samhain champagne and the ritualistic
sacrifice of crops and animals during
the festival are based on real life
while the cult of thorn and thorne
constellation are not but the name
thorne is based off of a letter in the
old english alphabet it looks kind of
like a p and a b put together so they
made the movie version just look a
little bit more thorny the thorn
constellation in the halloween movies
appears in the sky at seemingly random
intervals they're just the same years
that the halloween movies came out its
first appearance in michael's lifetime
comes in 1963 and this is the night that
dr wynn and his cult placed the curse on
the young boy forever changing his
behavior and making him an empty
soulless killing machine in my things
you missed episode on halloween 1978 i
talked about how michael's actions that
night could be interpreted as
representing a release of psychosexual
trauma that michael was too young to
understand i went in depth with the
psychological interpretation on that
video because it doesn't fall in line
with the information presented in
halloween 6 the curse of michael myers
so in this video since we're analyzing
his entire character that psychological
interpretation doesn't make sense
michael is simply possessed by the cult
michael meyer's power is described by dr
wynn as something greater than a man
driven to commit crimes evil
pure
uncorrupted
ancient
on october 31st 1963 michael's parents
go out for the evening and his older
sister is hanging out with her boyfriend
so he's left in the care of an older
woman named mrs blankenship across the
street he begins to hear a voice in his
head presumably this was the voice of dr
wynn or possibly the demon thorne itself
michael heard a voice he told him to
kill his family and that's exactly what
he does he grabs a knife and goes to
take out his sister by stabbing her
several times before his parents
eventually come home to discover what he
had done michael is sentenced to smith's
grove sanitarium and assigned to a
doctor named samuel loomis in a hearing
six months later in april 1964 loomis
was instructed to report on michael's
progress to the course two times a year
further michael audrey myers shall be
brought before the court on the day of
his 21st birthday where he shall be
tried as an adult michael was seemingly
in a catatonic state it's causing nearly
everyone to see him as harmless other
than dr lumens his initial stay at
smith's grove lasted 15 years none of
which is documented in the halloween
films however the non-canon chaos comics
material tells of michael's involvement
in more murders these stories
occasionally contradict the canon but
they were written to go in tandem with
michael's original story so no they
don't technically count as part of his
history but let's go over them briefly
michael was sentenced to rome with a
number of male patients one of which was
a psychopath named tony o'malley who got
into a scuffle with michael one night
before bed and had to be separated by a
security guard he was put off by
michael's non-speaking nature and plans
to attack him in his sleep but michael
was not asleep and shoved a crayon or
depending on where you're from a crayon
into tony's left eye tony was actually
one of the few michael victims to
survive but the cran or crayon pressed
up against his brain causing him to
become more delusional and violent
landing him in a padded cell for
solitary confinement in november 1964 a
juvenile named adrian wade who suffered
from an obsessive eating disorder ate a
cake that was intended for michael so
michael trapped him in the showers and
tortured him with scalding hot water he
was found unconscious with multiple
burns and later died in the hospital
weighing a heart failure years would go
by without incident and most of the
staff considered michael a model patient
but then in 1971 another young patient a
self-harmer named roger who claimed to
have witnessed michael's attack on tony
o'malley was found after supposedly
biting off his own tongue and choking on
it if you're familiar with michael you
can probably assume that that's not how
things really went down that halloween
one of the asylum administrators decided
to put on a halloween party for the kids
and michael wore a clown costume the
same costume he wore when he jabbed
judith in 1963. a girl named nancy
teased michael for having cooties during
a game of bobbing for apples lightning
struck the building causing the power to
go out and in the cover of darkness
michael drowned her and disappeared
before the lights came back up when
loomis discovers what happened he's
furious frustrated by his patient's
continued silence and nearly strikes the
boy before being stopped by his fiancee
jennifer jennifer mentions that she
believes michael belongs in a prison
which michael seems to hear and he
decides to make her his next target he
throws her off the roof of the building
and it is ruled that she made the jump
by herself what do all of these chaos
comics victims have in common they all
did something that michael didn't like
whether it's aggression stolen food
accusations general teasing or wishing
ill on him all of these characters
suffer from a form of revenge in the
cult of thorn arc that's not how michael
operates he's driven by a supernatural
evil that tells him what to do and he
has one goal which we'll talk about
later that's part of why the comics are
not considered canon so let's get back
to what is canon the original rampage
that would take place on halloween night
in october 1978.
[Music]
michael myers turns 21 years old and so
was due back in court to be tried as an
adult dr loomis and nurse marion
chambers were supposed to transport him
to his trial so michael took action to
make sure that this was not possible he
destroyed his room at smith's grove
freed many of his fellow captives and
left behind the word sister in blood
although to most this appeared to be a
reference to his older sister judith
because his younger sister's existence
was hidden from the public and she was
given a new name and new families that
she would be protected from any
potential harassment since dr wynn was
the administrator of the sanitarium and
also the leader of the cult of thorn
it's not hard to imagine that he didn't
exactly try his hardest to prevent
michael's escape michael waits for
loomis and chambers to pull up to the
sanitarium and when loomis gets out to
use the nearby phone he attacks marion
driving her out of the vehicle which he
takes for himself i know you can play as
michael myers in dead by daylight but i
think this is proof that he should also
be playable in gta
let's go bowling michael's ability to
drive without any training or experience
has always been a point of question one
that's even brought up in the movie sam
haddenfield is 150 miles away from here
now for god sakes he can't drive a car
he was doing very well last night when
you consider the fact that michael is no
ordinary mental patient but rather more
of a vessel for this ancient evil known
as thorne this starts to make more sense
throughout his story we discover many of
the powers granted to him by thor so the
ability to operate a car doesn't seem
that far-fetched during his 1978 rampage
michael is trying to recreate the
experience he had when killing his older
sister in 1963. i like to think of it as
a ritual that he established when he was
six going after his older sister and now
he's trying to recreate it going after
his younger sister when he was six he
wore a one-piece clown suit and mask his
halloween costume so this time he puts
together a similar attire he runs a
mechanic's truck off the road and
annihilates him to get the one-piece
suit and when he gets into hattenfield
he breaks into the general store and
steals his now iconic mask in place of
the clown mask he also steals some rope
which he would use later next he breaks
into his old home which now sits
abandoned when they later investigate
the house they find a dead dog which
loomis has his own explanation for he
got hungry
okay he knows his patient best so i'm
willing to accept that explanation at
this point his sister laurie stops by
the house to leave a key under the mat
at the request of her adoptive father
who's a realtor who is trying to sell
the place michael sees her walk up to
the front door and leave the key but he
lets her walk away and stares at her as
she makes her way towards her school did
michael immediately know that this was
his sister or did laurie become a target
simply because he was angry that his old
house was being sold we'll get our
answer a little bit later but for now we
just need to know that michael was
planning to make laurie one of his
future victims i also wondered why he
stalks lori throughout the day instead
of just killing her right now he follows
her to school and stares her down
through the window during her english
class then after killing some time
skulking around the elementary school
keeps surveillance on lori and her
friends as they walk home from school
when annie yells out at him he even
stops and seems to consider killing them
all right then and there but doesn't so
what's the big hold of obviously the
real reason is that the movie would only
be 22 minutes long if he killed them in
daylight but also in 1963 michael was
given his curse as part of the festival
of sour champagne and if we go back to
the holidays origins in celtic ireland
it was celebrated starting in the
evening on october 31st subtle isn't he
so if michael is waiting for nightfall
for the sake of tradition that may also
explain what he does next he stops by
the cemetery and steals his sister's
tombstone with plans to use it as a prop
during his recreation of her death
instead of an immediate sibling slice
and dice he just keeps an eye on lori
staring from behind some hedges watching
her through her bedroom window and
following her and annie as they head to
their babysitting jobs that evening when
they arrive he waits for them to park
and watches them go to their respective
jobs remember if you've seen my things
you missed episode on the original
halloween you saw me provide a different
interpretation for michael's behavior
that afternoon because i was analyzing
the movie as a standalone story but in
this horror history episode i'm
analyzing michael's entire character and
the context provided by the sequels in
this timeline changes how i have to look
at him it's all about the family
connection because michael has to
sacrifice his entire family before being
freed by thorne of course having a
massive amount of restaurants or
continuity like this can kind of mess up
the story if you aren't careful and
let's face it this isn't saw the
continuity wasn't the biggest concern so
the next thing that michael does is go
after the sex craze teens babysitting
across the street from the doyle house
where lori is babysitting if i'm gonna
try to slap on a reasoning for his
actions here the curse of thorn is
what's telling michael what to do and
thorn likes human sacrifice so any extra
victims that michael can decease along
the way are bonus points even if they
aren't a part of michael's family it's
like how i might go out to get a steak
taco but once i see the menu i'm
probably gonna add the nachos cinnamon
twist horchata and probably like three
additional steak tacos if we're being
real the way michael goes after his
victims can only be described with one
word unsettling everything he does is
very methodical from his slow walking to
his empty staring into space to his
complete silence as he does it all this
creates the impression that he's
essentially a blank slate devoid of
character almost like a machine
programmed by the curse that's been
placed on him this not only fits the
idea of the character essentially being
a shape that does these things without
interjecting any personality but also
taps into elements that the human mind
perceives as unsettling the core reason
that people can easily be off put by the
idea of voyeurism goes back to basic
survival instinct when humans lived in
the wild if another lurking animal had
eyes on them it was most likely a
predator getting ready to strike so were
genetically predisposed to be
uncomfortable in these situations and
avoid them one of the first studies on
the sensation of being watched was
called the feeling of being stared at a
title almost as fitting to its content
as the title of that 180s movie with the
blob which was called the blob the
article's author dr edward tichenor
disproves the idea that someone's gaze
itself could be what gives you those
goosebumps that unsettled feeling you
get is something that you give yourself
in fact an actual voyeur isn't even
necessary you can get creeped out just
by believing that you're being watched
michael takes advantage of this by
popping in being seen by the victim
de-stalking and then disappearing
leaving his target to wonder if he's
still somewhere nearby zeroing in on
them with that piercing stare lori the
boogeyman is outside look
tommy there's nobody outside but it
would not be long before michael meyer's
apparent voyeurism would escalate into
much more dangerous behavior
michael's night continues as he focuses
on lori's friend annie who's babysitting
at the wallace house across the street
he starts by locking her in the laundry
room then after she gets out he
eavesdrops as she makes evening plans
with her boyfriend and by evening plans
i mean michael hides inside of her car
she drops off the little girl lindsay
across the street at the doyle's house
and when she comes back she hops into
the vehicle to go pick up paul and he
lets her discover that she's not alone
before getting down to business and by
business i mean killing her
[Music]
he didn't even have the courtesy to
phone paul and let him know that his
ride is cancelled he moves annie's body
inside for later use when he comes back
downstairs he discovers two more horny
teens have appeared linda and her
boyfriend bob who are getting added on
the couch after they move things
upstairs bob heads down to the kitchen
for a drink and michael surprises him by
doing this
he pins bob to the ball with a butcher's
knife then further conceals his identity
by dressing up as a bed sheet ghost
which i mean if he wanted to pretend to
be bob in order to trick linda he's
already in a costume he's rocking the
mask and jumpsuit but i guess the
bedsheet ghost maybe does a better job
of concealing his physique because he's
much more physically imposing than bob
putting bob's glasses over the ghost
costume is enough to convince linda that
that's her boyfriend and when she turns
her back to him to call laurie he
strangles her with the phone cord with
all three of lori's friends across the
street out of commission michael turns
out the last remaining lights in the
house much like how the sanitarium went
dark before he took out his fellow
patient nancy in 1971. he then arranges
the body of annie in the upstairs
bedroom under judith meyer's tombstone
as a tribute to his first ever attack
and waits for his younger sister to
stumble upon it linda is stuffed in the
closet and bob is hung up in the closet
with the rope that he stole earlier good
planning after discovering this lori
stumbles out of the room in a mess of
emotions and michael emerges from the
darkness of the room next door in what
is probably the coolest shot in
halloween she's chased back across the
street and tries to defend herself by
sticking a knitting needle through his
neck which does cause him to drop to the
floor for some time if you're watching
this video you probably already know
that michael myers is invincible and
this is a result of the powers he
acquires by being cursed by the ancient
demon thorn but at the same time he
isn't just an unstoppable machine
hurting him enough will put him down for
short periods of time which i refer to
as his recharge periods when he comes
back to he follows lori back up the
stairs and finds her tending to the kids
but now his focus is on his sister he
finds her hiding in a bedroom closet and
busts through light's on no lights off
lori resourcefully pokes out his eye
with a coat hanger which puts him down
long enough for her to get out of the
room and get the kids out of the house
michael gets a quick ab workout and then
comes for her once more and she's only
just able to rip off his mask which
completely shocks him for a moment this
is one of the few times that we see his
face as an adult and he looks shocked
almost like the mask is such an
important part of this ritual that he
can't believe that she's removed it as
he puts it back on he's shot by someone
in the dark and stumbles back into the
bedroom it turns out to be his old
psychiatrist dr loomis who unloads five
more bullets into him knocking him off
the patio and onto the doyle's front
lawn but as always michael's ailment is
only temporary and he flees the scene to
riku he hides out in a back alley as the
police close in on the doyle house now
left without a weapon he goes up to a
random residence to restock and arms
himself with a carving knife stolen from
mrs elrod's cutting board then just to
make sure the knife works i guess he
breaks into the house of their neighbor
alice and successfully tests it out on
her i could try to dissect why the
elrods got to live and alice didn't but
i think it's better not to part of what
makes this iteration of michael scary
for audiences is his unpredictability
you don't really know when he's going to
strike this must be when michael broke
into his old elementary school and left
this clue that would later be found by
police it's a childlike drawing of a
family on halloween potentially
michael's family with a knife stuck into
the sister on the left there seems to be
an already discarded body which probably
represents judith meaning that this girl
with a knife in her most likely
represents lori and this answer is one
of our questions from earlier on in this
video initially it was unclear if
michael knew that lori was his other
sister when he first spotted her at the
meyer's house and i speculated that
maybe he went after her because he was
simply upset that she was involved in
his childhood home being put on the real
estate market so this drawing if i'm
interpreting it correctly which will
surely be up for debate would prove that
he didn't know about laurie and he was
targeting her specifically he also
paints the word samhain champagne onto
the chalkboard as a tribute to his
demonic lord thorne since the curse of
thorn that has afflicted him all of
these years is part of the ritual
carried out during the festival of sahan
champagne it seems like the lesson on
the chalkboard may have already been
there when michael arrived but it's also
possible that it's no coincidence seeing
as how it's an astronomy lesson and the
date of each of michael's homicidal
rampages is determined by the alignment
of the planets in the solar system at
this point news of a killer in
haddenfield is spreading all over the
media which at the time meant tvs and
radios and michael overhears where
laurie is being taken from this cowboy's
boombox yeehaw roll it
there
strode is found directly across the
street from the home where the murders
took place the teenager was taken across
town to haddonfield memorial clinic
he must have been getting close to
michael's bedtime or something because
after hearing this he just lets the next
17 teenagers he crosses past with go
free seriously i counted he just goes
straight to the hospital and dumps out
the rest of his cherry slurpee in the
dumpster he probably heads downstairs to
hide in the nursery before continuing on
to the storeroom where he's able to
slash through the phone lines
effectively isolating lori and the
hospital staff from calling in outside
hell one by one he takes out each of the
staff members at the hospital taking
care of lori starting with the security
guard mr garrett who gets tomahawked
with the pointy end of a hammer and then
an emt named bud gets choked from behind
after making love to his girlfriend
karen in a hydrotherapy bath after doing
so he cranks up the heat of the bath to
over 130 degrees fahrenheit in
preparation of his next kill
[Music]
remember how michael used a ghost
costume pretending to be bob in order to
get close to linda earlier that evening
now michael pretends to be bud while
karen's back is turned and when he gets
close enough he dunks her repeatedly in
the back in my opinion this takes the
cake in terms of brutality
they say that burning and drowning are
the two most painful ways to die and
this is a combination of both in fact if
you look at the top tens which is a
website that lets the internet vote on
ranking things people have agreed that
burning to death and drowning would be
the two worst ways to go of course we'll
never know for sure seeing as how
everyone who participated in this poll
was still alive but you get the idea on
top of that i can only imagine the
stark's terror that karen felt because
she thought she was in the safe
protective hands of her boyfriend and
she turns around to realize that it's
actually this terrifying masked mat
she's also undressed so add a feeling of
vulnerability to the equation and this
is just not your ideal way to spend your
final moments it seems like michael just
wants to clear out anyone who could pose
as an obstacle to him getting to lorry
and the next person in his way was most
likely nurse virginia alves michael
catches her in one of the surgery rooms
and ties her down to an operating table
then hooks her up to a severed iv
catheter so she's unable to move as her
blood slowly drains out of her body he
continues to the office of dr frederick
mixter and prescribes him with 20 cc's
of medication injected directly in his
right eye then when nurse janet marshall
comes to check on him michael appears
out of the dark and jabs the blood
vessel on her temple with an air-filled
syringe which essentially creates an air
bubble in your bloodstream and stops the
flow of blood to the brain which is
usually lethal it seems his very
straightforward and methodical way of
going about things doesn't hold him back
from getting creative with some of his
kills with all of the staff that
regularly walk the corridors of the main
lobby either dead or trying to find help
michael has free reign to slow walk his
way right into laurie's room uncontested
now armed with a surgical scalpel he
sees his target apparently unconscious
due to the medication that she's on and
decides to get stabby
[Music]
when he realizes she's not there he
looks to the security monitors to find
her and heads in her direction but first
he comes across a conversation between
the last two remaining hospital
employees a nurse named jill franco and
an ambulance attendant named jimmy he
overhears jimmy instructor to drive to
the sheriff's station for help if she
doesn't find anyone in the east wing so
while she's searching the other side of
the building michael goes out to the
parking lot and disables all of the
vehicles by stabbing their tires and
cutting their fuel lines as jill comes
back in michael hears her calling out
laurie's name and goes towards the sound
just before she realizes he's there he
drives the scalpel into her back so hard
that he's able to lift her off on the
ground with a small blade holding up her
entire weight this is where another one
of the abilities that the curse has
granted him starts to become clear in
addition to being immortal he's also
acquired superhuman strength with one
more staff member out of the way and his
main target finally in his line of sight
again he goes after her but his refusal
to walk anywhere near a normal pace
doesn't do him any favors and lori gets
away in an elevator however it's not
long before michael catches her outside
how about that he's almost able to reach
her before someone lets her back into
the building michael just crashes
through the door like a deer in a hair
salon
and sees dr loomis and nurse chambers
trying to protect lori his old
psychiatrist is armed and ready and
shoots him five more times bringing the
grand total to 11 on the night as we've
seen to be the case whenever michael is
attacked he collapses temporarily but
cannot die the state marshal that came
with dr loomis goes in for a closer look
stupidly assuming that michael had
stopped breathing and michael springs to
life and splits his throat loomis and
laurie retreats to another operating
room so michael bust down that door too
bringing him within striking distance of
his doctor loomis's gun jams and michael
takes the opportunity to stab him in the
guts when he corners lori she fires a
couple shots at him which apparently
lands just above his eyes i guess
judging by the fact that the mask
doesn't have any bullet holes the drip
down from his wounds temporarily blinds
him and rather than just using his
hearing to try to locate her he just
kind of flails around the room in the
general direction where he thinks that
she might be for some reason lori is
audibly whimpering too so it should have
been kind of easy not one of michael's
finer moments somehow though he is able
to hear the hissing sound of the gas
tanks opened by loomis near the front of
the room but before long the sound
surrounds him the last thing he hears is
the voice of his psychiatrist
[Music]
this is easily the biggest blast that mr
meyers has yet to endure with the
mechanics of his invincibility and
recharge period still mostly a mystery i
can only assume that it was his sheer
willpower and determination that kept
him going because he knew he was so
close to finishing his sister off he was
able to force himself to go a little bit
longer before collapsing again as he had
when suffering would-be fatal blows in
the past so to laurie's absolute horror
michael actually walks out of the blaze
literally covered in burning flames
before finally his body can take him no
further and he falls face forward where
he would continue to burn until the fire
department arrived and found him in a
canoe this time a much more permanent
one as he would spend the next 10 years
in this comatose state this time instead
of being taken back to smith's grove
michael was locked up in a higher
security facility known as ridgemont
federal sanitarium where despite being a
vegetable for his entire stay he gained
a reputation for being the devil himself
and even the guards were afraid of him
as for the room that he's locked in
welcome to hell after 10 years of being
in a coma it doesn't look like michael
is ever going to come out of it and it
was decided that he should be moved back
to smith's grove to open up space for
other more threatening patients dr
loomis is still michael's doctor during
this time though it's said that the
position is more ceremonial many of the
day-to-day decisions fall on the
ridgemont medical administrator dr
hoffman michael was to be transferred on
october 30th 1988 one day shy of the
10-year anniversary of his rampage extra
precautions are taken to ensure a smooth
operation however disaster strikes when
the ride to smith's grove doesn't quite
go as planned
during michael meyer's original stay at
smith's group sanitarium he was assumed
to be relatively harmless as more and
more time passed he was relatively
catatonic and only dr loomis was able to
see through him and understand that the
patient was still dangerous it seems
that michael employed a similar tactic
at ridgemont because while it's assumed
that he's still comatose during his
patient transfer he is secretly awake
and conscious to hear the transfer
personnel discussing his living
relatives did hoffman say anything about
living relatives yeah a niece living in
his hometown clearly michael is sentient
during this ambulance ride it would be
hard to say for sure how long he's been
awake before this but given how he
tricked most of the sanitarium staff as
a kid i wouldn't be surprised if he was
faking his coma for the last couple
years now the information about who his
living relative is is also important
because of the curse of thorn even if
lori wasn't around anymore he still has
to take out the rest of his family in
order to spare the community at large
once he hears what he needs to hear
myers breaks free and demonstrates his
unbelievable strength by shoving his
thumb through the man's forehead into
his skull they make it just south of
mill creek about 4 hours outside of
haddonfield before the ambulance crashes
probably the result of michael attacking
the driver it ends up flipped over in a
river and talk about rolling the ambo
but that wasn't even the end of the
suffering for at least one of the
passengers we can actually see carnage
smeared all over the outside of the
vehicle which would suggest that one of
the transfer personnel actually survived
and may have tried to escape the crash
site only to be reeled back in and
gutted by michael myers since his
signature mask and jumpsuit burned up in
the fire in 1978 michael feels the need
to get back in costume and stops at the
local auto shop called penny's garage
here he finds a stake and uses it to
impale the mechanic and take his
jumpsuit he ends up hanging the guy up
in chains in the back of his tow truck
it seems that michael likes to make a
spectacle of his victims whether that be
the shrine of babysitters in 1978 the
unique cause of death for each of the
hospital staff the capsized ambulance or
now the strung up mechanic this like
many of his actions may go back to thorn
perhaps michael wants to show off his
work to gain favor with the ancient
being or maybe he just does this to
intimidate the survivors as much as
possible because he enjoys it he goes to
a small diner attached to the garage and
relieves the waitress of her duties by
the looks of it this one died of
strangulation if you don't like the
service you don't have to leave a tip
but damn he also destroys all of the
telephones a tactic that worked well to
buy him some time before the authorities
showed up at the hospital in 1978 so why
not try it again here it would seem that
he's looking for his next victim inside
the kitchen when he's confronted by his
old friend dr lumens his doctor tries to
slow him down with another round of lead
but this time he gets out of the way and
tries to strand loomis at the garage by
stealing a tow truck and using it to
sideswipe the gas pump to blow up
loomis's cough
now that he's got a suit and vehicle the
next item on his list is getting a mask
and he's able to find one at vincent's
drug in haddonfield actually the one he
gets looks like a cheap knockoff of the
one he had which makes sense because his
actions 10 years ago made the mask more
popular so they probably had to be
mass-produced at lower quality he also
has a chance encounter with his niece
jaime lloyd the living relative that he
heard about earlier but like he did with
lori in the past he waits until
nightfall to come after her he stalks
the house that evening and after jaime
and her adoptive sister rachel head out
for trick-or-treating he does a little
investigating and confirms jaime's
relationship to laurie strode he also
gets his stabbing hand warmed up on
rachel and jaime's dog because he's an
athel we know in previous situations
that michael has thrived in the darkness
like the blackout of the sanitarium and
his turning off the lights in the
wallace house this time he goes straight
to the source the power station in
haddonfield and throws a technician into
a transformer not only electrocuting him
but also causing a blackout in town he
then completely massacres the police
station and leaves the place in ruins
and without a police force save for a
couple of stragglers on a foggy back
road he finds rachel who is supposed to
be babysitting jaime that night and
scares her away at least i assume that's
him it's hard to say for sure with all
these imitators running around rachel is
soon picked up by the police with jamie
in tow and again i assume michael is the
one who sticks around to see where they
head however the car disappears out of
his site so he breaks into a different
police car which is stationed at jaime's
house and hides in the back seat in
order to catch a free ride to wherever
they're going although the house is
supposedly locked down michael still
finds a way in somehow and eyes his next
target deputy logan who's in charge of
guarding the front door once loomis and
sheriff meeker leave the house he makes
his move literally tearing his head and
hand from his body michael takes a page
from his murder of bob sims and linda
vander clark the decade before by
pretending to be someone else he sits in
logan's rocking chair until the
sheriff's daughter kelly meeker comes
along and in another similarity to the
bob simskill he impales her body against
a door this time using deputy logan's
rifle to do set that leaves two more
human obstacles in the house for michael
to get through before reaching jaime
rachel and her love interest brady
michael finds them on the stairs and
brady tries to fight him physically but
is easily no match michael lifts him up
and crushes his neck and skull with his
bare hands he conveniently finds another
carving knife in the loft and comes
after rachel and jamie with it onto the
roof of the house where he narrowly
misses turning the elder of the two into
a rooftop halloween decoration he
eventually knocks her down onto the lawn
where she falls unconscious but jaime is
able to escape however michael hears the
security alarm going off at the
elementary school and decides to search
there for her suddenly having blonde
hair for some reason he ambushes dr
loomis and throws him out of the way and
he goes flying through the door like a
doberman through a coffee table
michael after quickly popping into the
bathroom to die his hair back to normal
appears on the stairs behind jaime and
he's actually able to grab her after she
falls down the steps and is unable to
get back on her feet however rachel
saves her when she shows up to blind
michael with the fire extinguisher
sprayed in his face if malcolm in the
middle is to be believed this could
actually work however as per usual with
michael myers his blindness is only
temporary and he's actually able to
sneak past everybody and latch himself
onto the bottom of the truck that comes
to rescue rachel and jamie he clings to
it as he be lines out of hat and fields
anyone who's ever had to do the arm hang
in gym class knows how much strength
this requires i think i can handle it
though
he climbs up while the car is in motion
and defeats all three of the illinois
boys riding in the back before punching
through the window to tear the face off
the driver rachel takes the wheel and
tries to buck him off with some sharp
turns but when that doesn't work she
resorts to slamming the brakes
vocabulary time i'm gonna call that a
break eat
michael gets up looking ready to line up
and block for the chicago bear's offense
so rachel just channels her inner
linebacker and tries to run him over and
since this would be a fatal blow for any
normal human it knocks him unconscious
for a period of time a confused jaime
wanders into the roadside ditch that
michael is lying in and grabs his hand
it's my understanding that this action
causes a mental connection between the
two that he was transferring part of his
curse on to her
after being rammed into a roadside ditch
with the full force of a pickup truck
the life comes into michael myers just a
moment too late to attack jaime and
instead the police and the remaining
illinois boys all opened fire on him
with seven men all firing shots michael
is knocked back into a hole michael
myers is not usually one to back away
from a fight but i think this time he
realizes he's overmatched and not
wanting to end up back in a high
security mental hospital he crawls away
and finds an opening to wiggle through
just before the police drop a stick of
dynamite into the hole to try to finish
him off he ends up floating down a
stream to quickly get away and ends up
at a homeless camp and when it's scruffy
inhabitant comes out to investigate the
disturbance this happens
i'm guessing michael just runs out of
energy i think it's been well
established at this point that whenever
michael survives death he needs some
time to regenerate his power to recharge
himself we saw him take a quick rest
after being struck by the pickup truck
but he never recharges after being shot
up by the gunman because he needs to use
a little bit more of his energy to get
out of there before the dynamite goes
off and just puts him in another coma
it's just like at the hospital 10 years
ago after the explosion he's able to go
on a little bit longer if he really puts
in some extra effort so michael was
essentially just delaying the inevitable
and he runs out of power once he gets
some distance from the police it's not
clear what happens directly after that
but michael would continue to hide out
there for an entire year once again
using the days surrounding halloween as
the time frame for his violent ritual it
was october 30th 1989 when he finally
took the knife to his off-the-grid
cohabitant not the nicest way to treat a
guy who gave you a free place to live
for a year but i guess at this point
you've probably realized that michael is
not the nicest guy the next day he hides
outside of the carother's house then
breaks in the back and spies on rachel
she gets herself ready to go out after
running around in the house for a while
he decides that he's waited long enough
and gets her with a pair of scissors
through the chest rachel like many of
the victims that michael took out this
halloween is deposited into a shrine
that he's building in the attic of the
myers house i already talked about how
michael loves his shrines later rachel's
friends tina and sammy come over to look
for her so michael decides to stalk them
for a little while michael's just trying
to relive the good old days back then it
was teenage babysitters now it's teenage
house sitters they'll take what he can
get the next victim that year's
halloween is tina's boyfriend mikey my
goal gets a rise out of him by leaving a
scratch on his car when mikey tries to
start a fight over it he stops him in
his tracks by grabbing his throat and
whacks him with what looks like a garden
fork keeping up with the tradition of
pretending to be someone else he steals
mikey's car and wears the mask that tina
got it she gets into the car thinking
that she's being picked up by her
boyfriend to go to the halloween party i
just love barbaric men you'll love this
guy tana i also love how when tina tries
to kiss him he just takes it and then
looks at her it's even weirder when you
think about the fact that that's his
first kiss she asks if they can stop for
a pack of cigarettes so he stops at a
gas station and while she's inside he
switches back into his usual william
shatner greg nicotero looking mask a
sign that he was probably about to give
her the old michael myers special i'm
really running out of
advertiser-friendly ways to say that
michael myers killed someone okay
however before she gets back in the car
the police raid the gas station and pick
her up they'd been tipped off that she
was in danger thanks in part to jaime's
psychic vision and michael the real
michael myers that is flees the area we
see this iteration of michael meyer
start to shy away from crowds of armed
police officers because he knows what
can happen if he gets shot too many
times he'll have to do his recharge
thing and that gives authorities an
opportunity to potentially pick him up
and he wants to avoid going back to
smith's grove or any other facility at
all costs later that night he shows up
at the tower farm which is home to the
biggest teen halloween party in
haddenfield he sees tina sammy and
sammy's boyfriend spitz leave the party
and go into the barn next door michael
equips himself with a pitchfork and
pitches spits out of the way before
grabbing a scythe and harvesting sammy's
neck when he comes out of the barn his
local infamy actually works to his
advantage because the cops assume that
he's just a kid that they saw earlier
who was dressed up as michael myers i
can understand why a lot of kids dressed
up as him in 1988 during halloween 4
because it had been 10 years since the
babysitter massacre at that point but
dressing up as michael in 1989 in
haddenfield when 17 people lost their
lives to him the prior fall and he's
still a wanted criminal on the loose and
most certainly somewhere in town because
it's halloween maybe that's just not the
smartest move but anyway with their
guard down he's easily able to take out
the cops with the pitchfork he gets back
in the car maybe planning to go find
jaime when jaime just shows up on the
scene with her little friend billy this
boogeyman business is getting way too
easy the victims are supposed to run
away from him not the other way around
he starts by chasing down tina by
intentionally driving slowly after her
jimmy and i talked about this in the
halloween five things you missed
everyone knows that michael myers walks
slow we're never given a concrete reason
for this but i've always assumed that it
ties into his curse i talked about how
he spent his first 15 years in smith's
grove in near catatonia he became known
for being this creepy unmoving shade so
he kept that aspect of his persona
intact by chasing his victims at a very
slow and steady rate relying more on
power than speed it doesn't often end up
being a detriment to him because his
victims are usually distracted
fear-stricken or stupidly brave so it's
not often that somebody gets away but
seeing michael go slowly after someone
in a car doesn't make a whole lot of
sense since we've seen in previous
scenes that he is capable of driving
fast the only explanation that makes
sense here is that michael is savoring
his kill he's intentionally stretching
it out because he enjoys being the
predator and maybe enjoys seeing the
fear on his victims faces and in their
body language
maybe this is also why michael
intentionally misses lori with a knife
so many times on that night in 78 who
knows before reaching tina he changes
course and comes after jaime and billy
reasoning for this i think maybe he
didn't see them right away i mean it's
pretty hard to do a character analysis
video on someone who has so little
character but that's also part of what
makes him great jaime zigzags her way
into the woods which results in michael
crashing the car into a tree and somehow
it explodes
[Music]
tina's boyfriend would be pissed if he
were still alive michael continues to
pursue jaime on foot and due to her
injured leg it looks like he might get
her until tina sacrifices herself to
give jaime more time michael uses the
knife for this one a true classic never
goes out of style
wait wrong franchise that's when the
rest of the police force shows up to
rescue jaime and billy and after they're
safely escorted away loomis meets
michael at the edge of the forest with a
message he tells michael that the rage
that drives him will not go away if he
kills everyone the only way he can get
rid of it is to face it where it first
began his childhood home on labkin lane
this is the first time we've ever seen
an internal struggle inside of michael
for the last 26 years of his life he's
been consumed by this curse of thorn all
of his actions have been motivated by it
for the first time since then we would
see the real michael myers creeping to
the surface
[Music]
before heading home to the myers house
michael first makes an appearance at the
haddonfield children's clinic this is
where jaime and billy live this
accomplishes a few things one michael is
able to determine that jaime isn't there
as promised by loomis who is with her at
the myers house two it draws the police
in that direction making it easier for
michael to get back into his old home
and three he attacks one of the officers
guarding the clinic and steals his squad
car which he uses to drive himself to
lampkin lane and rear-end the only cop
still defending the perimeter shortly
before smashing his face onto the
dashboard he makes his way inside and
loomis meets him downstairs and tries to
convince him to put down the knife
telling him that jaime is the key to
putting an end to the rage inside of him
michael actually hesitates and lowers
the knife at first and for a moment it
looks as if his psychiatrist is finally
getting through to him this shows that
the human side of michael myers is still
down there somewhere and although we
don't see it often he does want to
escape the male addiction that's been
inflicted upon him it seems that the
rage wins over in the end though because
he comes to his senses and slashes dr
loomis across the torso then tosses him
down the stairs michael goes after jaime
but she scurries away so he gets his fix
by tying a rope around this cop's neck
and tossing him out the window michael
chases jaime downstairs then down to the
basement then upstairs then up to the
attic jaime discovers what happened to
rachel and her dog max and in a
last-ditch effort lies down in the
coffin that michael has set up for her
and attempts to have a heart to heart
with her uncle surprisingly jaime is
actually able to get through to the
human side of michael myers in a way
that dr loomis was never able to she
asks him to take off his mask and when
he does jaime sees a tear running down
his face she even comments on his
humanity you're just like me
i'm gonna talk just like you
however michael's moment of humanity
peeking through is short-lived when
jaime tries to wipe away his tears and
the rage takes back over she runs
downstairs and when michael comes down
to find her he finds dr loomis offering
her to him this must have been a
surprising turn of events it would be
like if susan just showed up at my door
and handed me the gold creator reward of
course it turns out to be a trap which
if susan shows up at my door i'm
definitely gonna assume it's a trap shut
that door
a large net of heavy metal chains falls
from above considerably slowing down his
movement as he loads michael up with
tranquilizer darts then just goes to
town with a plank
[Music]
yeah
michael wakes up in jail but this time
his stay in captivity wouldn't last long
as dr wynn decided to take matters into
his own hands to make sure that his
protege lives up to expectations wins
single-handedly raids the police station
he makes quick work of the seven
officers stationed there and blows the
door off michael's cell where the two
can make a quick getaway despite being
free again it would be a number of years
before the planets aligned properly for
michael to make his next samhain
champagne sacrifice
now if you're riding along with us here
on the halloween express we've just
finished halloween five and we're moving
on to the curse of michael myers there
are two versions of this movie the
theatrical cut and the producer's cut
which was publicly released later
they're basically the same movie the
biggest difference is the endings which
is why you'll ride all the way into the
station with us no matter which one you
choose and your decision will really
only dictate which platform you exit to
the theatrical cut is technically canon
so that's the direction i'll be heading
in but if you want to see me talk about
the producer's cut check out the things
you missed episode it's been six years
since michael escaped the jail cell
leading many to speculate if he's dead
or alive it is october 30th 1995 and
jaime lloyd is pregnant with her first
child she's kidnapped by the cult of
thorn shortly before the delivery so
they can either pass the curse on to the
baby or let michael kill both of them
but a nice nurse helps her escape with
her firstborn after six years of waiting
in the shadows michael is dispatched to
stop them he pins the helpful nurse up
on a wall completing his trilogy of wall
art victims and snaps the neck of a
random guy who gets in between him and
jaime but she manages to get away in a
vehicle michael uses a smith's grove van
hunter and runs her off the road into a
pumpkin patch she attempts to hide
inside of the adjacent barn but having
just delivered a baby that day there's
not much energy or fight left in her and
after seven years of waiting michael
finally brings his niece's life to an
end by picking her up and skewering her
on this piece of farming equipment it
seems like she's already done for at
this point but just to make sure he
proceeds to turn on said farming
equipment for the first time in 32 years
he actually managed to make some
progress on his main goal which is
sacrificing his family members
unfortunately for him he cannot be freed
from his curse just yet because now he
has jaime's baby to track down she is
the last of his bloodline no no no
she's not the last the next day is
halloween october 31st 1995. just as he
always does when he returns to
haddonfield michael visits his childhood
home but this time he finds another
family living there this is the strode
family the relatives of the couple that
adopted lori all of those years ago
naturally michael is not any more a fan
of someone living in his older room than
he was 17 years ago so he deals with
these negative emotions in the same way
he deals with everything in life by
killing them the mother in deborah
strode gets cut down with an axe but
michael and maybe the nicest thing he's
ever done for anyone is courteous enough
to put her stuff in the wash it looks
like she had spilled some cherry
slurping on it the father jon strode is
thrown into a breaker box in electrocute
like mikey's car six years before he
inexplicably explodes
jon and deborah's son tim and his
girlfriend beth are at the live airing
of the haddenfield halloween radio
special michael goes there and ambushes
the host inside of his van the body
would later fall out of a tree
terrifying the spectators later still he
returns home where tim and beth are
already getting hot and heavy tim jumps
in the shower afterwards and asks beth
to bring him a towel but michael brings
him one instead tim doesn't notice the
thorn symbol on his wrist though so
michael gives him the old throat slash
when he gets out and proceeds to stab
beth in the back in the theatrical cut
the edit is very youtube poopish
[Music]
that just leaves john and deborah's
daughter kara strode and her son dany is
the last two inhabitants of the house
cara manages to hide in a dark corner
and knock michael down the stairs making
her the first one to knock michael out
with her bare hands he comes back and
grabs her ankle she's trying to get dany
to safety though and she's only able to
escape by whacking him with a fire poker
he chases them back across the street to
the boarding house but dr wynn and the
other cult members are waiting for them
there so michael is instructed to return
to his home away from home the smith's
grove sanitarium
that brings us to the last morning of
the original halloween timeline november
1st 1995. november 1st is one of the
worst days of the year as it is because
it's the furthest day from halloween on
the calendar i can only imagine that
having an immortal serial killer after
you on that day doesn't make it any
easier to swallow jaime's baby who's
been named steven strode and kara's son
danny strode are captured we have to do
a little bit of guesswork to figure out
what the colts overall plan here is but
i think the plan is to kill the baby
which would effectively lift the curse
of thorin from michael and give them the
opportunity to place it on danny that
would explain why he's been hearing the
voices in his head just like the
six-year-old michael did the evening
before he was possessed to kill judah
michael's quiet yet destructive demeanor
has surprised many of his 60-plus
victims over the years but what he does
next is a different kind of surprise
michael turns against the cult of thorns
walks amongst us brother he's come back
and
he's very angry
tommy and cara have one close encounter
with him and then he just walks into the
lab and starts cutting down doctors
nurses and surgeons left and right if
you work in medicine in haddonfield just
take the day off on halloween seriously
we're left yet again to wonder why
michael's behavior changes so suddenly
i've seen it suggested that he was just
tired of obeying the cult i think that
makes no sense why would he turn on them
when he was potentially so close to
breaking the curse after 32 years i see
it as more of a caged bear situation
while michael is possessed by thorne
he's essentially like a wild animal
anyone who gets too close is in danger
of being killed by him that's just his
nature what he does he doesn't have any
real allegiances but he does still have
the goal of killing off his next of kin
i'm not saying that he's incapable of
thinking for himself i mean we see him
sneak up on people and make reactionary
decisions throughout the series i'm just
saying that if he has the chance to kill
he's probably going to during this
massacre one of the medics escapes out
into the hall and that's when he sees
tommy and cara trying to flee with the
two young kids this is the first time in
a while that michael is really close to
completing his main task that is wiping
out his bloodline so we see him actually
walking faster than he's ever walked
before tommy closes up this gate in
order to create a barrier between them
and michael which totally screws over
this medic for no reason michael bashes
the guy's face into the bars and then
just knocks down the gate anyways having
spent 15 years there this is kind of
like michael's home turf so he's able to
take some kind of shortcut to cut them
off they duck into a random lab filled
with human embryos or babies growing in
tanks some think that this means jaime
was artificially inseminated to have
stephen others believe that this was a
setup for a seventh halloween film that
never happened i don't think either of
those makes that much sense because
these embryos are clearly growing into
babies outside of the body i mean this
isn't a typical ivf lab and this lab
scene was actually added for the
theatrical cut after the death of donald
pleasance who plays loomis it would have
been an excellent opportunity to tie up
any loose threads not cast new ones feel
free to share your own interpretations
though michael punches through the door
to get access to the lab and tommy seems
to concede to him and offers up the baby
but of course it's just an empty bundle
of blankets tommy stabs four syringes
into him and then cara hits him with a
pipe over and over he pins her to a lab
table and chokes her but he lets her go
after dany yells out and gives away his
position
michael realizes that dany has the baby
and attempts to seize him but tommy
drugs him one last time giving kara and
the kids a chance to make a run for it
then tommy beats him up with a pipe dr
loomis-style
yeah he's a little too proud of himself
there and believe it or not that is the
last we ever see of the original
iteration of michael myers the
theatrical cut ends with a suggestion of
some kind of confrontation between
michael and loomis where loomis managed
to get his mask off but judging by this
sound
i am led to believe that michael
ultimately got the upper hand the
original continuity ended with a whimper
in terms of box office revenue four five
and six represent three of the four
lowest grossing halloween movies as of
2021 i don't really care about that but
from a horror perspective it makes sense
why the series was falling out of favor
the cult of thorn storyline gives an
explanation to michael meyer's creepy
and unpredictable behavior and in a way
that demystifies the character the years
i've been convinced there must be some
reason some method behind michael's
madness but at the same time as we've
seen in this video there is still a lot
to speculate about i think back to the
sheer look of confusion when lori
removes michael's mask in 1978 michael
operates at his highest potential when
he the mysteries of his character and
his true intentions are properly masked
click that playlist on the left for my
entire catalog of halloween franchise
horror history episodes if you love
horror and all things halloween remember
to subscribe to cz's world for new
horrors every week ring the death bell
and select all notifications and i will
see you in the next one assuming the
planets align